good morning Hank it's Wednesday we now
return to the French Revolution where at
the end of 1789 King Louie the 16th and
his wife Marie Antoinette find
themselves under house arrest in Paris
while the French National Assembly is
trying to write a constitution we shall
skip the Year 1798 except to note that
one the National Assembly was not making
anyone less hungry and to the financial
crisis continued and also three a lot of
nobles were starting to take their money
and leave France because being a noble
in France which had once been among the
very best jobs in the entire world was
suddenly becoming sort of dangerous and
unprofitable these nobles were called
the emigres only I'm pronouncing it
wrong because I'm American and we
pronounce everything in America by the
middle of 1791 Louie and Marie
Antoinette were starting to think you
know that emigrate life sounds pretty
awesome but they couldn't leave France
because they still fancied themselves
the king and queen of it so this general
named boo yay comes along and says
listen come live at my estate in the
French countryside
blue skies clean air no revolutionaries
plotting your destruction for making
this offer by the way boo yay would
later be likened to a bloodthirsty
despot in the French national anthem but
anyway in July of 1791 Louie and Marie
Antoinette decide to light out for
buiiets Country Estate they dress up as
servants have their servants dress up as
royals sneak out of their house arrest
and if you've ever read a Shakespeare
play you know what happens next the ruse
is discovered and everyone lives happily
ever after
well the ruse was discovered anyway
still dressed as servants movie the
sixteenth and Marie Antoinette are
captured in the city of Varennes just
one day after leaving and they are
humiliatingly returning to Paris and
their servant get up but the worst part
about all of this is that some of the
more radical revolutionaries including a
group called the jacobins argue that we
the sixteenth leaving Paris amounted to
him basically abdicating the throne and
that therefore France has no king which
means that France can now become a
republic alright so the next month July
these Jacobins have a huge petition
drive in the sharp DeMars and lots of
people come to sign the petition saying
yes the King abdicated his throne we
should be a republic and then troops
controlled not by the king but by the
Nash
assembly show up and end up firing on
the crowd killing 50 people now you'll
remember the National Assembly was the
voice of the revolution the people who
started the idea of a representational
government for France who went to that
indoor tennis court in Versailles and
pledged not to stop until we have a
constitution but suddenly it's the
National Assembly firing on a crowd to
try to control revolutionary fervor you
see this all the time in history during
economic contractions what looked like
radical hope and change a year ago
suddenly becomes the man but by
September of 1791 the National Assembly
finally finishes its Constitution
fulfilling the Tennis Court Oath and
ushering in a constitutional monarchy in
which the Legislative Assembly has most
of the power but the king has veto power
on certain things around the same time
Frances neighbors start to get pretty
nervous about all this talk about
representational government especially
the Holy Roman Empire which as Voltaire
once famously noted was neither holy nor
Roman nor an empire the Holy Roman
Empire was a loose confederation of
states and the Holy Roman Emperor was a
guy named leopold ii who is not wholly
not Roman and not an emperor since
basically he only directly controlled
Austria but he was Marie Antoinette's
brother also like a lot of monarchs
leopold ii liked the idea of monarchies
and he wanted to keep his job as a
person who gets to stand around wearing
a dress pointing at nothing owning
winged lion monkeys made of gold and who
can blame him leopold ii figured that
having a neighbor turned into a republic
might be bad for his job security so he
along with king william frederick ii of
prussia issued the declaration of
pillnitz which promised to restore the
french monarchy and naturally further
radicalize the revolutionaries in france
also it's worth mentioning again that
noting that the assembly or the jacobins
or king louie xvi has done has done
anything to address the underlying
problems which is that the French people
are hungry and the country of France is
broke but then in April of 1792 finally
King Louie the sixteenth and the
National Assembly agree upon a plan
let's invade Austria the idea was to
plunder Austria's wealth and also sure
of the food
supplied by stealing delicious Austrian
cuisine also the revolutionaries thought
that they might be able to like topple
all of the European monarchies and
spread revolution through the world
which made Prussia a little nervous so
they immediately joined Austria in a war
against France
so by August of 1792 France is still
poor people are still hungry but now
they're fighting two wars and it is then
that a group of radical revolutionaries
led by the jacobins arranged for a
parliamentary session to which they
cleverly do not invite the vast majority
of Parliament and declare France to be a
republic thereby invalidating Frances
year-old constitution and then things
get pretty bad pretty fast allow me to
introduce you to my friend the
guillotine during the monarchy commoners
and Nobles have been put to death using
different methods but of course that's
not going to work in an age of
enlightenment the thinking went that
capital punishment should be egalitarian
and rationalist so everyone should have
the same death and it should be humane
because of course rationally we don't
want to hurt condemned criminals we just
want to kill them which is precisely
what happened to King Louie the
sixteenth in January of 1793 thereby
making it very difficult for Austria and
Prussia to fulfill their promise of
returning him to the throne within a
month of decapitating their king France
was it war not only with Prussia and
Austria but also with Spain Great
Britain the Netherlands and Portugal in
short things seemed pretty bad but don't
worry they're about to get much worse
Hank I'm gonna stop there for today so
Marie Antoinette can live until tomorrow
afternoon my last French Revolution
video will be uploaded tomorrow and then
you will educate us further on Friday so
I guess that I will see me tomorrow at
which point I promise to prove that I'm
not wearing pants